You've Got The Optimist and the
pessimists many people will tell you I'm
a bit of a half empty guy we are what we
say we are we're all the same right all
human beings all born the same all got
the same Minds it's all happening the
same but some of us look have been more
optimistic yeah and it's a habit it's a
thought habit you're not always that is
every one of my thoughts positive and
yeah this is good and it's best for me
no people who suffer from negativity
after they've said something it is
negative they must then finish it with
something more positive that's gonna
happen and if you do that in every
single sentence that they do that'll
become a habit welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host Hisham azuz and on
this week's episode I was joined by
Christian Boyle this is a slightly
different episode but a very important
one one of the biggest factors to your
success within recruitment is your
mindset and Christian Hoyle is a
performance and mindset coach I really
enjoyed uh watching his journey from
afar sharing some great content on
LinkedIn and I was really excited to
have him in the studio and what we spoke
about in this episode was everything
from unlocking your inner confidence why
we have limiting beliefs and ultimately
how we can build the mindset the
resilience that we need and want to
achieve the goals that we want in our
careers in our personal life enjoy the
episode
Chris welcome to the podcast thanks for
inviting we make Mega excited to be here
thanks so much yeah look thank you so
much for making the effort uh yeah had a
bit of a a challenge challenging one you
got the call up you showed up had a
couple of people cancel for things that
they couldn't control so I'm super
excited to be sitting down with you as I
said the other week really enjoyed uh
connecting with you via screen got your
energy picked up on it really quick and
as I said I really enjoyed seeing over
the last probably definitely the last
like six or so months
um you popping up on my LinkedIn it's in
videos of you getting recruiters to
present share things so just to add
everyone just to give everyone a bit of
context before we get into this uh it's
going to be a slightly different one
this conversation but I think it's an
absolutely important one for me from all
these conversations the people that I
meet in our industry one of the the
biggest reasons why people are
successful is down to their mindset and
Chris I know I was looking at your
Journey you've been on a really
interesting Journey from
education to uh founding a clothing
company uh to now obviously over the
last three years being a performance and
mindset coach and why I'm excited to sit
down with Chris is yeah over the last
couple of years you found yourself
working with a bunch of different
recruitment companies working with some
amazing people in our industry even have
your son in in the recruitment industry
uh and we are today going to talk about
what has Chris learned since working
right industry what are the common
pitfalls when it comes to mindset what
does Chris find himself helping a lot of
recruiters with I want to get his
Frameworks uh principles that he lives
by and the things that he finds really
help people maximize their potential in
our industry uh from a mindset
perspective so that's what we're going
to talk about today but I guess as we
always like to do we like to kick it off
with a million pound question let's get
Chris's take on what he believes are the
common characteristics and traits of a
highly successful recruit in today's
markets let's start there
so uh yeah I'm totally excited to be
here mate just a quick one before we
start I learned a lot about you in a
very short period of time because I
observed your actions because it's not
what we say it's what we do and now you
went about getting me the organizations
the questions you asked the questions
that you gave me for today were just on
point so much they made me start
thinking in a different way and I saw I
saw what you've got it's really
impressive so yeah thanks appreciate
that so I'm only going to read off the
list once but it was quite exciting the
first question was characteristics of a
recruiter
I thought my son how nice is that it's
pretty cool so like enthusiasm eagerness
without a doubt you've got to be
enthusiastic every day every day is a
new day and you need to start and be
enthusiastic as soon as you've lost that
you've lost a Mojo you're not going to
be able to keep going forward
bounce back because I always say this
little thing this is life this is life
this is recruitment just like that the
highs are great and the lows are so low
and you've got to be able to bounce back
from every one of them self-confidence
it's a must it's like every in every
entrepreneur recruiter everything every
professional needs it self-confidence is
crucial you've got to believe in
yourself because no one else will
believe in you other than what you'll
believe in yourself you've got to be a
goal Setter you've got to have more
motivation than any other profession
that I've ever seen it's very
interesting I was having a chat the
other day how many recruiters now are
listening when they were younger they
said what you want to be when you're
older
I want to be a recruiter there wasn't
many you know what I mean but they fell
into professionality and they wanted to
do it optimism you must be an eternal
optimistic person because especially
when you're going to this year we hear a
lot about the recession different things
going on it's all about what can you
make happen not what what's bad's going
in the background it's what you face
with and you've got to make the best of
it so I just think that's so much
resilience belief you've got to be here
to fight you've got to have some fight
in you if you get hit if you get knocked
down and stare down you'll be there
forever but in recruitment what I've
noticed it's constant I as I'm not a
recruiter so I get to look at from the
outside you get some kicks in the face
around there and it's how you get up
from that I think you know what someone
else said to me recently said uh a lot
of our youngsters aren't really up for
it anymore I disagree because when you
go in Recruitment and I meet so many of
them they're up for it they're people
who are getting knocked down to the
floor getting back up and bouncing back
up not every one of them I'm talking
about the elite of him but I've been
massively impressed by the standard of
people out there and it's been like it's
been really nice for me I enjoy it I
buzz off seeing people seeing them move
on and making it happen uh last one is
just the process everything's a process
coming here this morning was a process
your process was things went against you
today and what did you do just go on
with it you kept going go back to the
process keep it going keep to the
process everything happens and yeah I
just think yeah it's tough being a
recruiter but follow them simple
principles and you'll get as far as you
can be with it yeah nice so I thought
like let's uh let's definitely I want to
really go into like principles and as
you saw you saw a bunch of questions
that I think would be really helpful but
why don't we just add a bit of color to
who you are and how you've arrived here
you used it used it a couple of times
you send it in your voice note this
morning and also when we're on um the
video call I think you mentioned it you
sort of said that you're the classic
story of a Father's Love father like who
didn't have a father basically so why
don't we just start there and why that's
like an important
yeah part of the journey or why you know
I don't know because you've said that a
couple of times yeah I say that because
it used to be my chip on my shoulder you
know I didn't know it was my chip in the
shoulder I mean you find this a lot I
can instantly when I work with someone
to sit down I can tell because you I
think about my my children they've got a
great mum and dad who support him 100 of
the way they give him confidence they
give him belief they follow him I ring
them every day I send the messages I'm
up when you haven't got that you need to
find it from inside and the fingers
especially when men what we find we're
doing is we're always proving ourselves
whereas someone from yeah it's so like
there's a certain calmness about someone
that's from a nice stable background but
when you haven't had that Advantage it's
in you and until you find out that day
what you're you know like I was always
proving myself always having to be the
loud one always having to be like the
cocky self-assured you know possibly you
know that fine line between confidence
and arrogance I think I stepped on the
wrong line quite a lot of the time I
think if anyone knows me probably
thought my past that's that was true and
I've learned about that and the
different difference really for me is
now is when you spot that like
like I everyone I work with especially
in that predicament I feel like I'm
their dad and I try not like my kids
because how I am with my kids when I sit
in a room with someone you've got me and
I'm going to be that for you and when
they're in that room I'm I'm your
biggest Advocate and I want the best for
you and I think that you know that when
people sit down I give them that and I
always think I've got this thing with my
own kids and I know they'd happily say
this I've always wanted to be what I
didn't get and I always do it all the
time you know and I have an amazing
relationship and it's like work you
create what you want by what you put in
you know what I mean I'm here today I
knew what my expectations were because
you put them to me by your actions you
didn't tell me what the expectations are
I just knew how you were doing it I knew
when I was coming what I was going to
expect and this is just part of it it's
brilliant and your podcast brilliant you
just come across really good and I just
think you know like we're all Unique
Individuals and we just need to find out
what that is and I can definitely think
that not having a not having the perfect
family thing makes you be the perfect
family thing and you know one of your
questions at the end which I don't have
an answer for friendly enough you asked
about a victim mindset I've never been a
victim of my circumstance and I think
that when people become a victim of the
circumstance it holds them back and I
think that I find it difficult because
I've never let that happen and I could
be just like loads of other people and I
couldn't and I'm not and I think that
one of my things that I give to everyone
is not to be that you know don't let
don't let the past hold you back just
live today yeah I think
yeah you can definitely take that for
granted what you're talking about like
like you've just said the way that you
described you support your children
and then someone not having that it's a
big difference and I think when you do
have parents obviously they can piss you
off you can get an order them these
things you can you can sort of take that
for granted but I think as you get older
and wiser you recognize sort of how like
you said foundational that was and how
much of actually a positive impact that
had
so why why don't we just why don't you
just share with us then uh you're a high
you're a performance and mindset coach
what does that mean yeah I always call
myself a mindset and performance a
mindset and performance coach let's just
yeah what does that mean so mindsets
like uh my personal Obsession so do you
know like you know if you get into
something that's your obsession it
becomes a beautiful thing to do and
you're passing on something that you
gift and your gift isn't something that
you were just born with you earned it by
practicing the process of moving forward
mindset's how you think how you think
about obstacles how you think about
challenges how you think about your
habits how you think you know what's
your view on life what's your
perspective so the way I look at things
is always in a way to match what's the
best possible outcome from it so when
I'm talking about mindset I'm talking
about it's a daily practice
in your life or from the beginning of
the day till the end of the decisions
you make during that day and how you
push yourself and how you believe in
yourself the thing with mindset as well
is it's not always Mega intact you're
not always this perfect being that you
are but you recognize when you've
dropped it you know you there's a
Persona a fixed Persona that we've all
got and we're all fighting and at some
point it comes in I can't do this
little things that eat away like a
gremlin in your mind it's about
recognizing that and moving forward and
changing it and flipping the thought so
when you talk about performance I love
this okay so I sit down with say I was
sitting down with you now you know
exactly what you need to do better I
don't know you do straight away and what
I've got to do is get in this little bit
in here open the little bit of a chest
because you let me in because you've got
to let me in to open it and when you let
me in you tell me what it is you know
you need to do to be better and it can
be absolutely anything it can be the
time of day you get up it could be if
you read it could be relationships it
could be your food could be a DA it
could be water it could be how much you
traveled it could be how you travel it
could be how much you sleep what you do
it's every single tiny little detail
that you need to improve to work out
that you're better within yourself like
I used to be when I was when I was
younger I used to get up five minutes
before I went out well I said five
minutes when I was at Uni and when I was
at Uni and I'd had a little kiddie then
so I had a kid early and I was I had to
do some building work they'd be outside
and I'd be in bed and then when I get up
run out and get there hey they'd be
annoyed so they're starting off in a day
they're annoyed with me I would be
stressed but I didn't see stress then so
I created it myself now I'm a minimum
hour before I even want to leave the
place because I realized for me to be my
best I need time to think in the morning
to do the process to get ready it's
actually an hour and a half if I have to
be honest because I fit in some exercise
and whatnot but it's like small things
and when they tell it yeah they know it
and you all you want to do then is make
an actionable responses between now when
you come back they're going to do
certain things to improve it and the
idea is that it makes something become a
habit because when something becomes a
habit you do it naturally you do it all
the time without even thinking about it
and if you can do that like some like
I've created some amazing habits in the
morning that have made my morning start
my day and then I'm in the right frame
of mind to keep going and the amazing
thing about them is and this is the
thing I say about mindset
life
is ups and downs so you're not all it's
not always going to be brilliant but if
you keep your mindset intact when it's
down and you act the same and you do the
same process same principles you might
not feel better but you will action each
other each of them different things that
you do and you'll get to where you want
to be by keeping to the process
so it's a matter of you yeah you are
what you do and if you do the right
things you'll perform better and it's
accepting that you know other ones like
people going to bed or going to bed with
the phone on all different things what
it is but I need to find out what it is
so I can remove it and they can be
better and move forward and perform
better so like and then let's just make
this a bit practical then so if I'm a
recruiter or recruitment business what
what does that actually look like so you
sit him down with me I think you've got
like a you've got like a a course that
you take people through other than that
like what does it actually look like in
practice are you sitting down and
coaching people on a one-on-one basis
once a month like what does that
actually look like so what I'll do is so
I'll run workshops so my first Workshop
they ever do is on mindset and it is I
don't want to say it but it's I think
it's phenomenal because it's the
ideology of what it is that you set your
own limits no one else and I use a great
example I love her nimu did the fighting
peaks in a really short period of time
his mindset is the most impeccable I've
ever seen and I do a little I use him a
lot because he has no limits you know no
one can do them 14 peaks in that time
but at the end of his things he says one
thing that susses him up in one simple
statement he says giving in
it's not in my blood and that's a simple
mindset thing because if you don't give
in that's the thing people give in you
know if you don't give in and you keep
going through a failure or a setback you
will always get to where you want to be
you know this man you rang me up on
Tuesday to ask me to come here and I
knew this was no offense this is good
for me people get to know what I do and
I know it's going to be great business
development people get to see what I can
offer and I can bring them to
recruitment agency I didn't think art
doesn't work my time till I thought what
can I do to my timetable to get you yeah
I said yeah yeah I said yeah and I'll
always say Yeah just something that
moves me forward so it's a workshop and
then what we're doing so yeah we do the
workshop and I have a range of different
workshops that covers a range of them
one of them is thinking about thinking
so important so we do the workshops and
it gives like a broad idea that I can
tell everyone within the within the team
but then we must sit down and I want the
one because every single person is
different what everything every person's
got a different life different way of
thinking different way of acting so we
sit down normally between 20 minutes and
half an hour and I have a chat about
how's it going what's going on what's
going well what's not going well and the
simple question then we start to go into
the box finding out what is it you know
you need to do that you need to do
better to be a better person or better
at what you're doing and they go on to
tell me some things and from that we
decide some actions so but in every
single session we do there's some
actions that they're going to take for
the next two weeks when I come back in
two weeks so when I come back in two
weeks I come back and sit down and the
first thing I say is we decided these
actions have you done it and you know
what you'll be your beers buy and this
is genuine
with 20 people
I get there first thing in 19 of them
are doing them every one of them because
we don't set on realistic expectations
that's the other thing to take into huge
account if you like it's like the
January yoyo data comes in I meet him in
the gym I'm always in the gym I got gyms
throughout the year and he comes with me
goes yeah all right mate I'm going gym
five times a week 1200 calories a day
free classes at night I'm not drinking
I've changed my whole lifestyle we all
know that's not gonna work I'm thinking
I've got great it's great mate I figured
I could keep up with that and I come
here all the time and so if you've given
unrealist expectation no one can do it
so you make slight little tweaks little
tweaks they say one percent a day every
100 days 100 a change the tiniest of
things that they feel they can do and I
know when I meet them again if they've
done them really easy we set them a bit
harder you know and every time we set
them and they go through them the idea
is to turn whatever we decided into a
habit because after a bit once I leave
because I normally come into a business
for three months and work at changing
some habits and then I'll come back
later on you know because what happens
is people do all the right things and
forget just get on with it one of your
questions which was what was amazing
about why do people uh you asked about
why do we all read the books and don't
follow it through I think like one of
the things that happens because people
forget you know like I've I've read
books when I'm 20 so I've read a book
forgot about it and I'll read it again I
think
I forgot about that I'll give it a go
and I'll use it for a bit and I'll stick
with the stuff that's good but some
other book comes some other you know
there's so many books so many ways to go
about it and so many constant changes
then you've got your own changing
environment that happens with you you
know we're in a we're in a changing
world so how so you mentioned habits a
lot and how important how long do you
how long what's the what's the what's
the days because it's it's definitely
it's mixed in that it's not it's not the
21 days or whatever it's not that well
they say 21 days I would say six weeks I
would say six weeks where it becomes
habitual we just do it I've got this
funny little one of my rights so this is
one of my so I live in the latest living
Kendall I literally live opposite
Kendall castle and one of my habits that
Eve when I've gone through times a
struggle I've always done this does it
make me feel better and now what it
makes me feel like
like so every day I take my dog for a
walk I run up the castles one minute for
it it's uphill I I'm running 100 Max I
do it every day I don't even think of it
so when I'm walking long I don't think
I've got to run to the castle I
naturally do it because obituary that's
in me I couldn't imagine not I do it
it's not easy it's really hard but once
I've done it I think first thing in the
morning I've got through that what's
next you know I've got into a cold
shower now that's my new thing that took
me a quite a bit of anyone Instagram it
is grim but it puts you back in the room
so every time I know I do it I think
I've done that what can I do next do I
do it easy no chance I sit I think come
on do it do it I put it on oh and then
if my neighbors must think God he gets
murdered everyone that's got something
going on and you know what once you do
it and it becomes consistent you keep
doing it and that's what I want people
to do turn it into a habit six weeks
okay so let's dive into the things you
picked up on then in these conversations
because you you would have sat down with
one of the great things about industry
is yeah you get people coming from all
different backgrounds which is really
cool right so what why don't I just
start then like what are some of the the
typical things the most common things
that you've seen in people
uh that holds them back when it comes to
Performance just what what have you
typically uncovered uh in people and
what have you found a lot of when it
comes to yeah limiting beliefs barriers
to their performance like what I don't
know what have you found most common in
people that yeah aren't able to get to
where they really like to when it comes
to yeah mindset or under that umbrella
definitely mindset definitely like what
with a negative mindset okay you imagine
like in mindset we talk about uh a fixed
mindset yeah and we talk about an open
and growth mindset and the thing is
we're all built up of them two things
but what I realize is I noticed when I'm
in the fix I think whoa what am I doing
I need to flip what I've just thought
then because it's going against it I
really am sometimes like everyone thinks
can I do this I don't know if I'm good
enough once I say can I do this I don't
know if I'm good enough that becomes I
action that and I turn that into
behaviors it was just a fart in my head
just a thought and if I let that thought
swim around the rest of my day lives
that I can't do it what happens if I
just change what I thought there so
sometimes I sat with people it's it's
the way the thinking when things happen
they think they take if yesterday was a
setback they'd bring the setback with
them and when you're in a negative
mindset it's like the Law of Attraction
like we attract things to us when we're
thinking negatively we're acting
negative our actions are negative our
behaviors are negative they are like
accumulate together and that's what we
draw to us and I constantly see people
do it when I see the top Builders if I
can spot straight away because they turn
up in that room they're eager they want
to listen and they're ready where some
people just turn up and I think they
think it's going to be a little bit of a
dig at them because they're going to ask
them to change or say they're not good
enough and and that's a difference
really that people who want to be top
building I want to be top Builders
because they're willing to do anything
to be top biller whatever chains you
need to make they'll make it whatever
thing they need to learn they'll learn
it they'll follow it they'll do that
they'll turn up on time they'll do the
timings they'll work extra it's like
it's their actions once again a lot of
people talk a good game I've heard a lot
of people talk a good game and I'm like
wow this guy sounds good but I'm already
knowing it's not what you say it's your
actions and people just need to say
action and I'll come back to again the
process it's sticking to the process and
like like if we stick to the process in
the good and the bad we'll always get
the outcome that we want it's about
following it through and not letting
setbacks or difficulties or mood thing
the other thing as well is mood some
people don't take ownership of how they
feel and like to blame other people or
events or it was that candida or is that
job and if they don't start looking
inside himself really like what did I do
wrong you know I love it like I work in
lots of Recruitment and listen to
something they actually genuine they're
not going oh God we're doing that
listening thing again they're going now
I want listen because I want to be
better I want to learn what I could have
done I want to learn your input how you
feel I could change my next phone call
because I'm motivated to succeed and
that'll keep happening and yeah I just
I just think that certain people I know
when they're not that bothered about
being there and it's not something like
a passion it's just a job you know
that's a difference I think really some
people turn it into a passion hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out Vin Cheri who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so you
said you said a few things there select
the negative mindset yeah like
um moods controlling them rather than
them take taken responsibility of their
emotions
so I was watching this is what I wanted
to ask you I think is one of my
questions right is uh I was watching uh
one of your videos on LinkedIn yesterday
I think it was like with link Healthcare
I think a lovely yeah so I think yeah it
was a couple of the recruiters
um just sharing that experience with you
and what what I picked up on
was the things that you're just saying
there which was a lot of these people
were saying I was feeling this or I had
this perspective on the situation I was
I was viewing it from a negative
standpoint
but sitting down with Chris it made me
realize no that isn't how I view things
and I can view it in a different way
have a different perspective right so
what I wanted to ask you was a lot of
people uh will uh view things from a
negative standpoint from a negative
perspective
now it might be easier for me if I sit
down with someone like you to help me
get to to view that at a different
viewpoint but I think some obviously
what I've found in my life and speaking
to people and I'm by no means perfect is
one of the biggest challenges here is
not being aware that you're viewing
things from a negative one from a
negative perspective and a negative
viewpoint
so like for people listening obviously
if they're if they're listening then
this might give them opportunities to to
learn and realize oh actually am I
someone that view things from a negative
place or don't have more I do have more
of a fixed mindset so what what's like
your advice for people if they're not
even aware like what's a good first step
a good action if they're not even aware
that they're viewing things from a
negative perspective that is holding
them back and because I think a lot of
people aren't aware that a lot of things
that you mentioned there requires some
sort of self-awareness
yeah it's interesting that because
you've got The Optimist and the
pessimist and the and many people will
tell you I'm a bit of a I'm a bit of a
half half empty guy and we are what we
say we are so straight away you're
telling me what you're going to be so
everything you say you've already said
that's who you're going to be from now
on you're like we're all the same right
all human beings are all born the same
oh we've got the same Minds it's all
happening the same but some of us look
have been more optimistic yeah and it's
a habit it's a thought habit and it
doesn't you're not always that and is
every one of my thoughts positive and
yeah this is good and it's best for me
no you didn't but it is you just said it
awareness being aware of what you say
and listening to what you just said
sometimes I'll say something and I think
that's not me I don't speak like that
and I'll think I need to reframe that
and change it so I was this isn't from
me actually I was actually I'd never go
I like the Diary of CEO yeah in fact I'm
obsessed about the sound that's the
number one I've listened to Davina
McCall was on it the other day you know
what I'd never ever choose to listen to
her and it randomly came on it was
absolutely immense yeah it was good have
you oh you listening yeah listen I'm not
halfway through well I'd never chose it
you know like sometimes you're not
choose things that comes on you think
this is brilliant So I listened to it
one of the things she said it was
referring that people who suffer from uh
negativity because they say it but after
they've said something it is negative
they must then finish it with something
more positive that's going to happen and
if you do that in every single sentence
that they do that'll become a habit so
they they've registered as soon as said
it they've said uh something negative is
going to happen but they finish it off
with however I am looking at making that
better so every down that they say they
make a positive outcome at the end of it
and they do it in every sentence and
that becomes a habit and it's like
you'll notice me say habits constantly
because thought habits you know like I
gave it to someone else I got someone
else what like so you asked me about
what I do with people I said I always
ask this
are you in a relationship and they say
yeah I go tell me what you are out of
10. and they'll say oh what do you mean
I'm going what are you what you what are
you out of 10 and then you don't know
what to say they give me a number the
number reflects that we want to get that
number I think our six I'm like I need
to get you to an eight because I know if
you have a happy relationship at home
you're going to be happier at work so
one of the things I said is when you get
on from work what do you do because
recruitment is a bit stressful come on
yeah people this is they know that
sometimes it's a bit stressful and
you've got to you know wind down well I
get in and sometimes for a bit I mean I
just leave her and I just go upstairs
sorry I'm using a man as an example
there and I just go upstairs because I
want you to start this habit I want you
to get to the door walking every day and
just say hey
how's it going how was your day
and I want you to do that every day for
two weeks keep that going every day for
two weeks
you know I mean you're looking at you
know what's going to happen don't you
whoever you say that to is gonna think
and they're going to say something okay
back because whatever that happened in
your day you left it where it was and
you came and you listened to someone
else and that becomes a habit then you
know and creating little habits like
that it's like you're greeting when
you're coming in the office in the
morning come in the office in the
morning greet everyone with a smile and
start with enthusiasm you're beginning a
positive day bring a mood that you've
just had with someone annoying you at
the traffic lights or a road thing
that's the day that's going to impact
you that day you know so they're all
habits you know and you can sort of like
it's just like being aware of them just
like like awareness is everything you
know you become awareness and be
accountable for what you think and now
you're out and you'll notice your
responses get better but how can we like
I would I want to get your take on like
because you must sit down with people
that aren't aware you can see it in
plain sight but they can't so for people
listening that yeah they may use the
language that you know what I'm not
actually very self-aware or yeah I do
let the emotions get the better of me or
I do yeah get in the frame of mind
that's negative and I can't snap out of
it or um they may not have been aware
that they have have that perspective
right so
what yeah like what what sort of good
thought habits or experiments can we
share that you found help people develop
more self-awareness it's interesting
that because I think everyone is aware
okay I think when you sit down with they
know what they like because like what I
said before you everyone the person who
knows you the best is you and people get
onto the fact that they know that what
their life's like because of how they
think and how they act they just don't
do anything about it and it's a master
Point actually it's about like
registering that like when you do this
you're creating you're creating an
emotion you're setting off and like I
want people
like
I want people to live the best life here
and your best life doesn't mean that
you're gonna have that it's not going to
be a brilliant life all the time you're
not gonna be happy all the time
everything's not going to work but you
can have the best life by always acting
the same to every single thing that
comes so when something comes and it
hits you and you're like and you're like
you bit caught out by it by a rejection
on the phone call clients let you down
at the interview or
um clients like you're an interview or
you've got a deal go down it's something
like that now can I overtake your whole
day move into your week or you can have
a way of resetting right lens for
instance if something happens to me now
and it's really annoyed me I don't want
to show me Show my emotion all right so
I have a think I'll mind the gap Victor
Victor frankly it came from a
concentration camp yeah I love it you
know I use it a lot because
I love the chain Paradox I get every
single it's very good especially men I
swear especially men the chimp like my
chimp has been a big problem in my
earlier life and I've learned to manage
him mostly but he's also my best friend
as well because he can get me out of a
lot of situations but I don't let him
run my life and I think like once you
start like the chimp parrot you know you
say a negative thing but that is your
chimp your chimp responds to negative
things and starting to understand why is
it you sometimes act like you do sort of
thing and you're like why do you respond
in the same way what you find is people
respond the same that you always add
give you another great book about mine
the Gap sorry I didn't interrupt to do
that also yeah man the Gap is the one of
the most useful things in the world and
I'll tell you who did it actually so I'm
working at a place called insight and uh
yeah I know we've had Sean on the
podcast I've got Sean yeah so when
they're in there they'll say oh I asked
John I asked Sean for summer and uh yeah
he said we're going to see the next day
and I was thinking Sean uses man in the
Gap because when you're a business owner
because I that's the other thing I've
been a big business owner so I when I'm
working at business I act like I'm them
because I know what they want and I know
what they can't say and I can say it
more because I have a relationship
that's different and I think that I
can't show my if I show my emotion to
what I really think and every decision
that comes in you won't see the real me
you'll see my initial emotion in the
moment my initial moment in the my
emotion the more is not me that's me
processing what's going on so I need a
bit of a time and that's what the Gap
provides us so if something annoys me
you'd often find that I'd leave where we
were I'd say can I can I I'm just gonna
go Tyler can I come back in 10 and give
it here because I don't want you to see
my emotion because I want you to see my
practical the way I actually deal with
things and in the moment my chimp which
is sometimes a little bit sort of thing
that will slow down what my actual
official response is I need a bit a bit
of time and I think if you I used to get
I used to get held to my reactions to
stimulus and that doesn't happen in my
life anymore because I try I don't keep
my reaction there and then because often
that's not who I really am and if you
can give yourself a little bit of time
in between that in between that you'll
find that what you give is your reaction
is actually you a bit of a circuit
breaker off well it's like sometimes
they said don't they like um
like I think we've all been there where
we've had something happen and we're
writing an email and it's straight after
something's happening it's like
yeah and then it's like why don't you
just dwell on that and then the email
that you would have written in the
emotion where it looked very different
to the one that when you gave you one
even just went to the toilet for 10
minutes or went for a walk the two
emails would have looked very different
right
see I guess I guess what you're saying
there is again
um being aware of that and yeah learning
learning about uh learning the fact that
yeah you're like you just said I think
that's really powerful that me reacting
or my emotions and me showing my actions
that isn't actually the best sort of um
showcase of who I am because if you were
to go away like I just said the email is
probably a good example is like that
initially mode right but then you go
away and come back that it looked very
different so it's like no you've
actually thought about it you tried to
maybe understand what's happened the
other person's perspective these things
and you've arrived at a place going okay
right I'm not as yeah emotional here and
this is how I'm feeling and like so that
that's super helpful then for people to
think about having some sort of
circuit breaker or yeah should I just
say this actually it's interesting like
it's text messages isn't it it's like if
you respond straight away to a text
message it's often not what you really
think and I don't want to say who this
is but someone very big in my life
massive who I love massively they won't
be listening to this anyway but I'm not
going to say who it is I love him
they've moved you know when you say how
do people change they used to have a
massive and negative uh existence in the
way they thought and it's funny now
because this is someone who's very his
family
they they used to send me text I'd send
a text and they'd send a note like
they'd send a chimp text
yeah right and that what I do is I'd
never reply to them and they'd always
think about it they'd go no they'd go
they knew my no reply was saying that
was that wasn't on what you just said
because Nino reply is I'm stuck at first
what we play a dawn but I've observed
them as they've become better at lean
less negative how I know it is so last
week they sent me a text one of them it
was deleted in three minutes I actually
saw it though so if I would have been an
hour later I'd just seen a deleted
message I saw them deleted because they
recognized that wasn't who they are now
and they were being their old behavior
and there's a book if I recommend a book
um I always get it's called Uh breaking
the habit of being yourself I say his
name wrong every time your dispenser
yeah yeah Spencer yeah yeah okay he's
got loads of podcasts as well so that's
what that's about that just because
you've always done a certain pattern of
behavior before doesn't mean you can't
change it and you know what people get
addicted to old ways of being and how do
to the to now I've got this beauty that
I have right
I love this is a great example
so sometimes when I meet with people I
say I ask them a question and they'll go
and this is this is a limiting belief
they'll go in my head and they'll give
this response and I'll go interesting
because when did you start establishing
so I'm going to give you something he's
53 this person I'm thinking of when did
you start in my head with that response
you've got to that and go well I started
thinking like that when I was 20.
so in my head's an expression that they
use for the it's like a controlled
behavior that they're going to tell you
that they've always done they're not
responding in the moment they're gonna
get they've always been like this right
you know when someone says I've always
been like this yeah and then I'll say
when did you start being like that and
they'll say when I was 20. oh that's
really interesting that because you're
telling me you were the smartest you've
ever been 30 years ago and you've lived
your whole life because that guy knew
exactly where everything was going
forward and they'll go no
and I'm going sounds a bit like it but
until they've registered and then next
time it comes up they'll think am I am I
answering this like I was oh I am and
that's the difference that's powerful so
I guess we're talking a bit about it
here but one of the questions that I had
for you as you described uh recruitment
being uh yeah definitely consists of
uh can consist of a lot of highs and
lows for people so what what other sort
of practical Frameworks then can you
share that you have found yeah help the
people that you've worked with or sort
of common Frameworks or habits that
people have implemented that you've
worked with that have that have helped
them deal with the highs and lows is
there anything else so we've spoken
about mind the gap is there anything
else I found that you know I found
interest for that question it's amazing
no one ever really asked about what to
do in the highs we always speak about
what to do in the last good point it was
an excellent question because it made me
think that
because because when I meet people who
have the heart he's the Creator because
the top Builders they've got a real
resilience about themselves and they've
got all the attributes I said before so
they manage that just as well it's
mainly when you think of the laws you
think about people struggling and that's
a lot of what I do when you said that
identify where I read those who are
winning always win you know they keep
winning because it's an action and it's
a habit you know and they're resilient
they get back up they keep doing it they
see you set but they don't see they see
failures feedback so it's for
interesting when I'm with them all
they're looking at is how can I be
better I can be better I can be better
because they're already on a high
they're just wanting to know what little
things can I do to be even better so
it's more when you put that question I
was looking at algae people to face the
laws yeah how do people first yeah
that's a good point actually that's
where you sort of where you where you
gravitate towards I think that's
everyone it was like really interesting
it made me really think on the train
actually so definitely the laws I think
cam it's you know stresses you know
stress let's say let's let's all right
first difference between winning and
losing is in your head that's what it is
because winners and losers just make
decisions that are best in their ad and
it's a way of thinking so we're back to
mindset again so that's a um that's a
big difference and um
I've lost my train of thought then just
give me what how like practical
Frameworks for dealing with the lows is
there anything else that you find
yourself or even exercises you know like
I sit down and just sit like if everyone
like yesterday I did it I was at
something and go yeah I don't know what
to do when I'm out there I get a bit
stressed and I find it and I said I said
just now just do me now just go
foreign
just off two hmm
completely change your physiology
completely changes it that's and I
always just do three because it takes a
bit of time and we only got short bit of
time that's three so if you're in a real
bad way you do ten you're complete even
off three you completely find yourself
rebalancing just like and you're like
I'm all right you're almost like
reconnecting with yourself you know like
breathing and breathing exercises
bringing it back down because when you
get a bit stressed your heart rate's
gone thinking you're all frantic you're
tight you're tense as soon as you're
concentrating on something else you're
not mindfulness getting away again I
always suggest get out the office a
minute just stand outside and just
observe because soon as you take your
mind off things because when you're in
the present moment everything's all
right the problems being when you look
in the future in the past and sometimes
we're all guilty of that and when you go
and get like go outside do the breathing
exercise a lot of them are going outside
for smoke I don't like I'm not smoker
but I think they're going outside and
they're dealing with that moment I don't
think that's the right way
go outside and just observe things and
start taking your mind off what it was
because as soon as you come back into
the moment you'll realize actually all
right what this little thing is is not
that big and all you need to do now is
do some actions and go forward and get
back to the process and I think that
people forget that the simple ways to
reset and me you know bring themselves
back into the room you know because
people are chaotic once you get games
things going wrong it's that negative
mindset it starts so we need to reboot
the system and I always find the
breathing exercises are immense you know
like but you forget because it's so
obvious it's like you know like the
thing is like it's like it's like
inventions you look yeah that's too
obvious that no the obvious is what
people forget simple little thing
lunchtime go for a walk you're having a
crap to go for a walk it wins not
sometimes every time you might be 100
you'll never lose it completely but you
come back in the room and you get more
logical you you're coming back to you
getting rid of your motion getting rid
of all the anguish that's come with
whatever that subject is you need to
remove yourself from it and just have a
little bit of a time to rebalance bring
yourself back to normal and it's simple
that sounds it no no yeah no it is very
powerful I guess what what I want to ask
you then spoken about some of the things
they're breathing going outside
um do you think
you can build resilience or are you born
with it
a hundred percent think you can build it
but I think that some like
you know
I look at my life I've had some tough
challenges yeah but they've now I when I
and this is a this is another thing that
I really love all my tough challenges
and some of them are pretty crazy I'm
not here to talk about them but I'd
never change them yeah we hear that a
lot yeah I've never cheer and so when
you're having a tough challenge yeah
it's difficult to see going through it
but just remember if you've never
changed the other ones this is building
you whatever's happening now is building
you so I believe that resilience is is a
thought in your mind about how you go
about it it's a thought about Not Giving
in it's not about moving forward it's a
talk about even when things are against
you you still show up you still get on
with it and once you start doing it
becomes a habit showing Up's a habit do
you know what I mean I love this stat I
got it off to diary CEO 90 of everything
we do showing up I'm worried about I
actually didn't worry about this I can't
wait to come genuine love it I love this
stuff it was like but someone else might
be worrying just show up once you're
here it'll do it it'll start it'll
happen on that phone call just pick it
up once you've got it in your hand it'll
keep going it'll happen and that's
resilience and in recruitment you know
like uh there's a a stride there's a guy
called Harrison who I absolutely love
and I saw him he like he picked he is
resilient he picks up the phone and he
gets told to f off yeah what does he do
it instantly picks a phone but dials
them back and he went sorry about I
think we got cut off you know what it's
stuff like that look that is resilience
and I think it's a process and you can
build it up yeah or you can think no I'm
not resilient as soon as I say I'm not I
become what I say I am why am I say I am
I'm growing more resilient every day you
I mean recruitment will make you
resilient if you're in it a long time
without a doubt I'll share out of it so
do you think you can only build
resilience then by going through things
yeah yeah yeah well what is life yeah
you know like all of life is going
through summer even those who you think
of having an amazing life they haven't
they're gone through some a personal
battle
um a relationship battle a battle with
it internally a battle in their
environment whatever it is no one's got
that amazing you know some of us have
got better lives than others but we're
all facing some kind of struggle
um
uh and then the other other thing I
wanted to ask you this is something a
big belief that that I have but I wanted
to ask you your thoughts on it with with
what you're doing they generally there
the euron is how how important is
personal responsibility within this
conversation because I think you
mentioned it earlier
I think um in the world that we live in
today I feel like it can be it can be
very we can always find someone to point
the finger at
and sometimes rightly so sometimes I
think it's a bit of a get out of jail
free card so how were the things that
we're talking about changing yeah our
perspective for the better being more
positive building more resilience how
important is personal responsibility
with as as part of that
absolutely everything I didn't you know
like that was one of the questions I
didn't even write anything down because
I think accountability personal
responsibilities everything like you you
you it's you that does everything no you
know like some people might have some
lucky breaks and whatnot they might have
it might be a family business and
they're going to do it and it's up to
them but the rest of us the majority of
that is like today your personal
responsibility you got let down today
what did you do it's got on you came on
you made the best of what you've got you
got it going you were responsible for
what went on and I think that
I'm responsible for getting up this
morning I'm responsible for going to bed
earlier last night I'm responsible for
making sure last night I got all my
stuff ready so I wasn't stressed this
morning because I coming here stress
it's not the thing to do you know I'm
responsible for everything I'm
responsible for our feel I'm responsible
for how I think I'm responsible for my
actions if something happens to me
i-tech responsibility even if you did it
to me because it's like how did I
respond to that how did you how did I
let someone else get in my life to do it
because every part of it when I look
back is a point that I could change and
it's like you asked about top Villas and
those at the top and those the highs
they do they are accountable
unbelievably when I was coming here this
morning
I buzzed off this I'll always say that
actions and words are different looked
on me Instagram story from three of the
guys at strive all six a.m boot class
this morning winners actions of winners
being accountable they know that in
recruitment I meet them all I exercise
for me
exercises everything for me because it's
it's discipline and discipline is
everything in life it's personal
responsibility is discipline and I
looked at that and I buzzed off it
because you know the end of the day
you're knackered I mean if someone
people do go end of the day but majority
you got 6 a.m you've done it then and
you can crack on with your work you've
achieved summer you've passed the first
thing your discipline Sean you're
already believing yourself you get that
belief you take it with you and it is
accountable and that's I think where I
where it goes wrong when I'm meeting
people they're not accountable for their
own actions
let's talk about that because like
that's yeah I'm I'm a big believer in
that but I didn't always think like that
and I didn't always immediately think
what could I have done better I
definitely didn't always have that
mindset
I'm not quite sure exactly what the
first step was or the journey to getting
more towards the way that you're talking
about things but I that that that's how
I approach things
so for people listening the uh aren't
quite there yet and like you just said
that sometimes can prevent people from
uh fulfilling their potential getting to
where they want to
how can we get closer to that like what
do we need to start doing to get closer
to more being more personally
accountable why did you change
yes good question
why did I change
I'm when so when was it and why
so the the story for me was really
quickly early 20s
30th March early 20s talking like yeah
22 somewhere around there
uh where it all all changed for me there
was definitely a moment
and it all catalysts from there so uh I
was a part of a friendship group and uh
at that point all I cared about was
going out pulling girls stuff that's all
it was that's that that was the the main
thing
um and then two of my friends in that
friendship group that I was close with
but you know you're closer with some
people than you are others but I started
to notice that they weren't coming
around to smoke weed and watch Geordie
Shore they weren't coming around for the
pre-drinks and going out
and I was really I I've always been a
quite curious person
my mates like to call me a journo
because I like to ask a lot of questions
but yeah that's my nickname question is
it yeah so um so I was curious as to
like why they were sort of branching off
from the group
and anyway long story short is what I
realized when I became curious about
that
was they made the decision and that
decision was that they felt their time
was better spent
focusing on themselves so the Epiphany
that sort of I had through that was the
best investment you can make is in
yourself sounds really simple and
straightforward but
yeah I like that that's sort of how I
arrived at that so then ever since then
that's when I've been interested in
personal development curious about being
the best version of myself and how do
you do that so it all started from there
I'd say and then it's just like for me
what's really freeing about the personal
responsibility and accountability which
is why I think it's really important
particularly with the world today in the
landscape today like if you woke up
every day and decided to
read watch everything externally and you
and that dictated how you felt about the
world and your perspective in these
things
like what chance have you got to think
that we've got a yeah like I'm happy and
these things there's so many every
single day there's reasons why I
shouldn't be happy or reasons why
the world's thoughts and these types of
things so like for me I think one of the
most freeing things you can do is taking
responsibility and the feeling like
you're actually in control because yeah
like when you don't feel like you have
control that isn't a nice feeling but
there's a lot you can control so I'd
rather I think it's a lot more yeah it
helps me and it's a lot more uh powerful
to be like no I'm what could I have done
better or I could have done this it's
just way more freeing it's I feel
lighter for it so
the main thing is I use this one a lot
control the controllables what's the one
controllable you can control all the
time how are you at yeah yeah you your
actions what you do how you think and
when you said before how does a person
who's negative you can control it
because you're the one who had the
thought so if you have a fart and you
know it's not going to help you out you
can flip it and you just have to become
aware you know like your true sense is
not to not to have doubt but doubt is
sometimes in us but doubt stops us from
performing so what doubt will do is is
let us down we need to get rid of doubt
and doubt gets rid of by believing
yourself making changes that's what you
basically said to me you made changes
I uh I there's nothing better than I see
than I sit down with someone
and we talk about changes and then I
start watching them make it and it's
like it's quite emotional I think
there's a guy called Dan gorad so it
reminds me of me he's a lot yours half
my age he uh is it strive right yeah he
works with my son
and um what I love about it and I mean I
love this guy obviously because people
my son you know I just yeah I work with
them you get very intimate in work you
know I I have a passion for everyone I
work with some people I just we we just
hit it off
and that we discussed a lot of things
that had helped him out and he was doing
already he was already doing really good
and then he started to do everything
that we discussed and it's once again so
I'm on his insta just watching her
perform a perform at the weekend six in
the morning up a hike doing something
else he's not he's stopped not going out
on the drink all the time anymore not
getting in that behavior starting to do
things that make him perform and he's
happier than he's ever been and you look
at him and you think this guy is doing
everything in order to be better but
then he does some more and it's people
like that I just think
because I just think I see me in him you
know not everyone's like me you know not
not everyone I meets like me and when I
meet somebody similar to me I know I
know we can work together and I watch
him and I think I've got a lot to learn
from them that's the other thing I want
you to know that I learned a lot from
these people I mean because I'm not
finished project you know I'm I'm ever
I'm into change every day I want to be
better than what I was
yesterday because today is a new
opportunity to begin so I love that you
know it's a beautiful thing to be able
to do what I do you know I kind of I get
paid for doing something I love but I'll
tell you one thing about it if I do a
full day I'll leave them I Lose My Soul
because I give everyone sometimes I
leave
and I need to be in check because I'm
dead I walk from that to that train
station and I slowly at my end because
I've got to give 20 people the same
energy and I do that's a lot it's a lot
but I realize so now I have to go I've
got to manage myself what do I do now
I've got to go into like fight back I
know what's going to happen I'm prepared
for it and I need to go like sell
preservation go with the flow because I
know that the next day it's a new day
and I'll be absolutely bouncing again
but I just need to take it easy and
that's the thing that people realize
when they leave work if work's been big
you need to work on you to calm yourself
down
um
so as we come to the end here then just
just curious to get your thoughts on
this you're you're a father yeah clearly
really passionate about being the best
dad you can be
uh how like yeah you you raising a
family
um in today's world mental health how do
you feel about that because clearly yeah
like that yeah that whole term would
have been completely different when you
were growing up I didn't even know what
it was that's what I mean so like how I
don't know how do you feel as a father
and yeah mental health and and as soon
as I've been the biggest killer young
man these days oh yeah that's been an
impact in my life in other areas but
um I see that mindset and well-being is
one of them things if you keep your
mindset intact and keep working on it
mental health will be further away from
you because you're always working on
being in a certain place I you're on
about my kids I've got this amazing
thing happening right now my middle son
who's gonna be a top 11 top
top Elite performer is currently at
strive doing work experience for two
days with his big brother watching his
brother on the phone being unbelie he's
it's like that's the kind of thing that
I can give my kids like you know you
don't do work experience in school
anymore they don't do it really that's
crazy so we took it on us not with funny
of Dylan sorted it and I looked at Luke
today is doing a pitch in front of
everyone about what he's learned about
Strife around the kind of people I want
him to become the environment I wanted
to be in and he's like I got to see my
son perform on a phone and sell the
dream and watch him and no one gets to
do that if I had a thought when I was a
kid I was going to be when I was younger
that I was going to watch my son do that
one of my proudest moments and the fact
my other son is watching my older son
perform he's just like
a special real special and I just know
that it's the beginning of him being an
unbelievable performer because he's
going to watch them people and he's
going to want to be one of them and he's
going to act like one of them and I
think that I've placed him around that
and I constantly my kids talk about
I don't talk about mental health or talk
about I go this is me and this is no
word of alive and I mean I do this like
you know like I I've had tough times in
my life recently I became single uh
beginning last year I didn't want to do
that I had to go and motivate everyone
when I wasn't feeling the best motivated
but mindset is always the thing that
gets you through it and when then I was
struggling about a walk in the morning I
go right come on wait more Lucas because
he's older so you know what it's like
getting him out of bed it's dragging
them out right Lucas up we go come on
today it's gonna be a powerful day for
you you're going to make some good
relationships and from the off you're
going to start achieving things from the
morning you can have the best day I want
you to go out and make your pet makeup
if people feel good and show everyone
who you are
and you'll be like oh God this is also
he said this to me before he's good dad
does everything have to be a lesson
I'll go I'm glad you said that that's
brilliant because yes he does
I love that that's awesome so look part
and advice
what do you want to leave with people if
they're still with us they're listening
they want change
what's the part and advice uh for people
who want to fulfill their potential when
it comes to to mindset what you're going
to leave them with okay so first one
I'll leave with Founders and MDS you
want to get me into your business and
business quite quick that's the first
one absolutely nvdb just if you'd like
so change can happen anytime you're not
a victim of the past and every if you
think yourself today is a day if today's
every day is an independent day and it's
up to you what you do where you go from
it and you if you failed in the past and
you've not been able to do it okay
that's fine but as long as you keep
trying when you keep trying eventually
you'll get to your goals that's what Rod
means today that if you keep trying
eventually successes come and you know
what coming in a podcast with you is a
sign of success of what I've been doing
that made me feel really good and I
appreciate that like from the bottom of
my soul but I know this is the platform
to get to speak to other recruiters
because I love the recruitment because
they need mindset I'm telling you
because it's the biggest test and I
think you can do it read get into it get
a mentor get around the right people you
said it before you said it when I asked
you what changed you it's who you knock
around with who you knock around you'll
become so like I notice in recruitment I
see it all the time I see it like
they're stopping knocking around when
people knocked around with at school
because they're trying to match who they
are now and there's nothing up with that
I still love my mates from school and
I've met one for the last two Mondays
and he's messing up and I've got a
responsibility to him because I said to
him because if I if I'm at your funeral
I'll be sad that I'm not doing out but I
don't do it all the time because I need
to be around the kind of people who met
me feel alive and met me when I look at
them and think I want to be them Place
yourself around them and you'll become
not a lot of that change can happen at
any time anytime honestly anytime
crisping absolute pleasure I've loved it
mate I've genuinely thanks so much I
wrote All Them Nazis questions so good
and when you said don't look at your
notes I thought oh my God what am I
going to say there we go
Chris thank you cheers buddy thank you
so much for listening to the episode I
hope you enjoyed it and got value from
the conversation if you did enjoy it
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
episode